hello hi my name is Annie chain and farm
purdue university and i just first want
to thank the organizers give us this
opportunity to present our work and as
the first line show today at my talk
about the world of activating cdc42
kinase in drosophila spoon Genesis so
what is activated cdc42 kinds so it is a
non receptor tyrosine kinase tyrosine
kinase receptor and now receptor ack one
is adnan receptor tyrosine kinase it was
originally identified as a noun we
should hide kinase i can bind to
activated cdc42 names the name ack
activated seas of the times in general
the domain structure has the n-terminus
sterile automotive followed by a
tyrosine kinase motif and then as
Astrodome in and then the quick demand
equip stands for cdc42 rack interactive
binding domain that allowed the final
6042 and then also follow with a
c-terminal keep recruiting association
domain that regulates the protein
stability of a ck and its substance so
when you compare ack to other mammalian
nhung receptor tyrosine kinase and they
are ten families and then ack is right
here a couple of thing that stands up
first the position of the sh3 domain is
c terminal to the tiny thurman and where
the other now we sort of having honey
they have their as a free domain and
terminal to the kinase domain so this is
just that ack is regulated differently
the second thing is the presence of this
food domain
this clip them in allow a security
blindingly 6042 which is a very
important regulator of cytoskeletal
rangeman and as well as cell polarity so
so this ack which is held in Kanye's
important for adoption in addition we
can bind to a very important regulator
of cytoskeleton so why use a secure
interesting so ack has been implicated
in cancer so when you do comparative
genomic study what's fun is that
horrible activity of AC aging correlate
with the ability of cancer cell to
metastasize in addition in chemo samples
mutation in a sea cave has been found is
probably done by thomas cook and
infiltration in the same domain kinase
and then HT domain then when they major
the mutation this mutation in vitro they
found this mutation usually increase the
ack kinase activity so again consistent
with idea that when you have too much
ack our function e correlate with cancer
in addition in a plastic answer it's
been shown that ack can respond to
activity of occupation of insulin
receptor EG receptor and you can
activate downstream oncogene such as any
to news after a katy or you inhibit the
activity are teamusa precision wwx so
therefore they simply some correlation
between ack and cancer and then so there
is an interest in its function as well
trying to use it as a target for our
drugs against council so many moons have
to a sequel a tagine wine co ack one
yellen called G and K 1 the major
difference between a ck one and keep the
NK one
is the presence of this web domain you
see quick domain in a ck one biosig for
coming in here and k1 and ack whines i
mentioned before has empathy intention
TM k 1 is less well understood but has
been implicated in tumorigenesis as well
when you have mouse knockout G&K one he
has they have elevated rate of
spontaneous tumors okay Padre sliced car
messed up but here shows the ACK family
again in a ck one you have equipped
domain in tnk one you do not have the
crib domain and then fasala would you be
the organism i described today also have
to ack family drosophila ack and
drosophila pr2 again the sequence level
ack is actually more closely related to
mammalian ack here's a base to suffer
ack is cause we eliminate ck but but
your supply ack Miss is missing the
equip domain on the other hand the just
self appear to have the crib demand by
the sequence level it's more distant
from mammalian a secret so now interest
in ack its role in endocytosis and in
mammalian cells even suggested that a
secret associate clapping and immediate
the interrelation of VGO receptor so in
this context ack is supposed to
facilitate the down-regulation of
activated receptor therefore it
negatively regulates egypt signal so
it's different from the previous world
were hyperactivation cause cancer then
consistent with this role in classroom
media and supposes basic has been shown
to in facilitating translational
transform receptor but this are this
role in this process is kinase
independent
and the recently an AC calm home logging
siagian set 3 has been found to be
required for into a similar transport of
double string s rrna so for those who
are not fill me with chlorine and then
clapping is a major pathway for
endocytosis and then he'll describe
debate the major pathway obvious process
so you have plasma membrane and then you
have a cargo which then has signal that
we cruise class when adapter then
clapping adapted by Chicago then we
cruise clapping strikes triskelion as a
clapping polymerize if for mom it forms
these cotton coated pits and then cause
of membrane imagination eventually you
have laughing Cody bicycle and this is
super from apartment by the action of
dynamin eventually you have coughing
Cody bicycle then the carton codes are
associated by the action of Ages 70 and
then exhuming protein so the idea is
that the ack associate class going and
it recruits add people to eat your
supper to calculate and then we move
them from the cell surface so you have
less signaling so part of this slide
again is kind of messed up here but what
it shows that another ace function ack
has is my cell death and then this is
shown by Jim come in drosophila shown by
our gym Clemens who identify ack bar is
a bill to bind to dark protein is an
adapter protein these were coming become
important later so what she showed you
is that if you express a gene a
pro-apoptotic gene like hill which will
cause I to be smaller then when you
overexpress the the odd ack the I will
become bigger so ack can prevent the
cell phone dying so all these are over
expression so now we are interested in
what is the normal function are
ACK and then we hope to do this then
when we understand what HP does on the
normal condition then we have a better
appreciation of sort of mutation allowed
in the class canceled so we use gisela
to investigate the normal function of
ack so just apply like mammals have to
ack homolog and we're gonna call them ba
CK and PR tube against you remind you
the ack has a higher sequence similarity
to mammalian ack one but does not have a
group remain so not a whole lot known
about ack in drosophila it's been used
by nick holland to study a process
called total closure so what those who
closure is given yourself embryogenesis
and leave the jump and retraction which
leaves a hole on the door so sad embryo
then the epidermis on a lateral side
will expand and then to close his hole
so filler do so will generate a hole in
this embryo and these prophets makes
sense because of this expansion of
epidermis on a letter side is supposed
to require two supposed to require 6042
and it was proposed that ack ack
downstream LCD 42 in this process
however the penetrance of this thing
that i was pretty low so it's not for us
it was not the best you know type to
study to use genetics so let it look
what else is affected by AC
communications ok so the field major
crushing we want to address is in
drosophila what is a cicada what does PR
to do are these two ACL homolog we've
done them and then what's the functional
link between ack family kinase to see
sequel to that's the important question
because this family of now we sort of
kindness is defined by the ability to
bind it's easy for you to and what's the
importance of that link
okay so first we work on ack so Nick
harden has general meetings ack 86 shown
here and if you lead the transcription
start site to make sure that this
mutation is no we use a probe probe
healed in a coding region and we show
that by rt-pcr that this AC 86 does not
generate any messenger RNA so it's a
non-real Minton's homozygous for a scaly
six are viable that indicates that ACK
it's not an essential Cinque the Flies
survive but the male flies are complete
sterile they do not really they do not
produce any progeny so to ask history is
caught by Freese I garlic or pose I
garlic mechanism we look at the ack
distance so what you see here is a
wild-type testes and then stand carrier
down one GOP which label the sperm tail
and also labels are for loading which
labels adding and then DNA so are the
important here is that down one GOP
which labels from tail so in a wild-type
you can see plummeted developing in the
testes in addition you see mature sperm
in deposit into the structure called a
seminal vesicle label by the for panera
here in ack mutant you still see
spermatid developing in the testes but
when you look at seminal vesicle they
are no mature sperm so somewhere along
the way ack mutation block sperm
development and then we actually very
happy when we look at the fly base to
look at the ACA expression during
development ack ack is expressed
ubiquitously but its expression is
highest in male testes consistent with
the fact that we see male phenotype
mystery phenotype
so then to understand how a CPA perturb
sperm development I'm going to give you
a quick crash course on a drosophila
from Genesis so here is avila are female
or just alpha male and then the length
of a typical fly is about 2.5 millimeter
drosophila has am usually long sperm the
mature sperm emailed average about one
point eight millimeter almost the full
body length so when you open up the body
cavity and I look at the testes you can
see each male have two pairs of testes
and and then um they a coil around this
structure right here is a cubic
structure right here and inside the
testes that's where the male germ cell
develop and then the sequence is such
that you have a hub at the 80 km then
you have the germ stem cell right next
to the hub the germs things that undergo
asymmetric cell division generally a
spawn ago neum which undergo mitosis and
meiosis and generate 64 interconnected
spermatid then this spherical is
committed under the dramatic cell
transmission elongate which one point
eight millimeter in length and it's
still connected that it is process
called in versation kyoto characterized
by these deformations acting cone that
moves along the sperm tail from the
nuclei and all way to tell em and which
will separate each spermatid into
several sperm
the sperm will coil and then they were
moved to the seminal vesicles okay again
we wouldn't in this because we were
studying classroom and then we know the
classroom is involved in this I green
the clapping involving germ cells and
then we were interesting how a secret
associate clapping may be involved in
sperm development okay so this slide is
simply complicated by it's not make it
basically is wild type testes and an ack
mutant testes staying for down one GOP
which labels from tail blew it DNA and
then phalloidin is the acting which
labels a kinkos so in a wild-type you
can see elongated sperm with vomited the
acting home have now assembled number
one number to represent the elongated
spermatid with an ethical ethical just
assembled and number three labels the
affirmative that i think on have
departed so in wild-type you can see all
three are stages in the mutant you can
also see one two and three all three
stages so as far as the number of
silicon stage visibility's little bit
between wild happening then when we look
at migrating cone in a while tell you
can see migrating cone here and a hi Meg
shown in an inside view and ensuring am
you can view again the morphology and a
number of parking cone migrating looked
the same the difference between
wild-type and meet him the first
difference we saw was in a spermatic
coin when the individualization is
completed is formally begin the coil you
see a nice coil in wild-type but we do
not see cohen in newton and i would
think the mutants are in the mutants the
test is actually your germ cell should
become tangled
okay so now we want to do is ask when
and where is AC K Jean required for
Colonel chances so to do this we put a
ck under two different promoters one is
beta children the other one is down one
promoter and in both cases ack is tagged
with n cherry so we can follow the
explicit expression both beta-tubulin
and down one are germ cell-specific
promoters in beta tooling the promoter
is on during spermatogenesis in an
elongated schematic but the ack
explosion disappear when the a king kong
begins to move the darwin promoter comes
is also germ cell-specific but comes up
much later it comes on when the acting
cones are assembled again ack disappear
when the comb begins to move so he'll
kind of this slide should summarize the
expression our temporal pattern of the
two different streams and what we show
here is that ACP homozygous that flies
are sterile and they are no sperm in the
seminal vesicles but he put ack back on
the beta tubulin now you can restore
male fertility as well as the presence
of sperm in seminal vesicles so it's
rescue on the other hand when you put it
down 1m Joey bag the male remains terror
and there is no sperm in a seminal
vesicles so conclusion here is that the
ack is required for spermatogenesis in a
cell-autonomous manner in addition we
can pinpoint a timing a requirement is
between us from a toe side and then that
before the ice the investment corn
assembly so using the rescue as an asset
we can ask our ack and PR to financial
redundant the answer is no if we put an
ACP back we can get a rescue you get
rescue here if we put a PR to back you
see no rescue and if we put a mouse ack
Mouse acct back even though monsees kid
has equipped you still rescue if we put
the mouse tnk back it does not rescue so
this demonstrate that the mouse ack one
is the functional home log of your
software HC k then doing this we can ask
what is the critical domains are
required for a skate functional genesis
so we put a bunch of mutations with the
LI the stare of motif we mutate a kinase
domain we meet we remove the HP domains
and then we move the clock in but inside
and then we move the uva so shown here
so wild-type full and rescues but if you
remove the stare of motive it's not
rescue so that indicate the stair
automotive is critical for HK function
also you pipeline a's and they required
the SS three domain ok so the next
question so we next question is where is
a cyclical basically localized so to do
this we have a ack tagged with n cherry
and then we look at that at a swimming
hole site and then we cross them with
the batteries of gfp-tagged organelles
cusub marcos so wrap five labels early
endosome wrap seven levels lena storms
rapidly 11 labeled recycle some minor QP
label mitochondria mostly GOP labels
membrane and then classroom Labor's
clattering as you can see here ack does
not overlap with rap five reps seven
rabbul alamin GOP it doesn't overlap
well with the membrane GOP buddy labels
very very
world with classroom GOP in addition
when you look at a classroom in GOP yes
you can see two population you can see
those population around the cell
periphery also you see population in
internal and those internal clattering
our next to go G so there are two
popular clothing those are involving
endocytosis and those are and those
involved in secretory pathway when you
look at ack ack only associated with the
end of silicon so the association of a
CPA with end of silicon lead us to
propose maybe ack is involved in
endocytosis so we look at adding has
been suggests in the moon cells that is
the case involved in interrelation of
each receptor and transferrin receptor
so we're looking at a process are the
internalization of the brightest
Seminoles in I risk so in I risk the
bright of service it's expressed on in
our a cells and then is internalized in
to enable himself which express the
cellular receptor so when you look when
you stained the I is a link from the top
you can see a big dot of armed boss
followed by drilling down applause the
big dark represent the boss on re
surface and then it's the small dot
represents the internalized quite a self
into a neighboring cells you compare
wild heaven ACK there's no difference so
this asset they should have no
difference in receptor-mediated
endocytosis of wireless an explosion we
look at the classy localization class
notation in ack now sells is no
difference so it's now affected and also
we look at another will establish a say
this is your south flower garland cells
the upper in the city even the arm take
on selling say gonzo has carries a rap
seven GOP and then and then incubated
cells in a red tracer after
as you can see a red tracer internalized
into the endosomal structure and you ask
there's a ck mutation disrupt the uptake
of tracer there is no so we look at it
we look at two or three different end of
silicic acid the answers if we cannot
find any and those silly feedback in ack
meters so our conclusion is that ack has
no role in endocytosis and if there's a
row is very minor or cargo specific okay
so that we have shown that the arm the
same domain the kinase domain and then
the HT domain are required for a sec a
function then we ask are they also
required for ack and localization the
answer is is still a motif it's required
for escalation when you look at here
when you delete a single man ack becomes
a department however the kinase domain
the kinase domain even those requires
function it's not requiring for
localization the kind is that ack still
associated with crackling positive
structures okay so then the key question
is what are the fat to define to this AC
curve climbing's then a lot of our
housing kinase associate with adapter
protein so we ask does ack associated
with NC k which is an adapter cocaine
with three as a strudel man and one is
true and this is educated guess because
biochemically arm cassava educates being
shown to interact with our the dark
which is the fly homolog instigate in s2
cells so we ask we ask is dark also like
ack require for fly male fertility and
the answer is yes and this
is kind of how to do because dot
neutrons are lethal dark as me
implicated in axonal part finding so the
way we do it is we generate dart
meetings and we put wild-type back da
while type dark back into the new on
ourselves and then the Flies are viable
but the test is still missing dark
proteins and shown here in wild-type you
can see lots of sperm the middle shape
sperm in a semi best ghost in a dark
Newton testes they are no sperm so dark
like a ck it's required for male
fertility then there's dark and a skate
for more complex the answer is yes if
you do an IP with n-type dark protein
then you take the precipitate and do it
on a Western you can detect a ck protein
so it is a wild-type wild-type so x-ray
can detect a scape protein and if you do
use encho ack you also can detect a
mature ack forms a complex with dark
proteins in addition when you look at
you presently colocalize here is a dark
grp they exist as the secures of
structure around a cell periphery you
overlap with a ck very well furthermore
the dark localization requires a ck so
here is darker localization in wild-type
spermatocyte it is seen as specific
structure along the cell periphery but
in the ack mutant that localization is
gone what's left are this wing wing
structure they are the label is the
cytoplasmic buijs between interconnected
from a toe sense if you put wild-type
ack back you can restore dark
localization shown here so dark it's in
green and a sebacean red however if you
put the kinase dead ack back doc remain
miss localized so that says
importantly that ack kinase activity is
required for dark localization so then
we ask the dark protein which domain is
required for its input r is on
localization the SS three is dotted line
to put in which region of other protein
that s s2 is start to find two
phosphotyrosine so wild-type dark again
you see the circular structure alone a
cell periphery when you mutate the SS to
that localization is lost it becomes son
apartment if you mutate it as a three
you still become it remains less secure
so that suggests that a ch2 domain is
critical for dark localization in
addition we can do a Calliope and we
notice that when you mutate the SS to
the ability of dark to kauai p with a ck
is reviews from one hundred percent to
twenty five percent so dark it's
critical for its localization as well as
ability to interact with a ck ok so
another important thing is a ck is auto
fast Foley so this is shown and this
simple Western here so we
immunoprecipitated for length ack and
inclined instead ack from testes extra
and you can be teleporting like blotting
with antibody against venturi then when
you plot the same blood with 4G 10 which
detect us tyrosine you can detect the
ack protein full important but not the
kindness death virgin so the suggester
ack is phosphorylated and then that fast
version requires its own kinase activity
so we can cook ack decayed is out of
phosphorus so what what is going on is
that ack dimerize through
same domain and that same domain is
critical for dimerization so if you
delete a single main aisa geet cannot
dimerize and it's not functional once I
see Kate dimerize the auto fast foods
and then January's generated
phosphotyrosine which allow the issues
coming up dark to find to the
phosphotyrosine then which leads you in
drosophila least respond to colleen by
in cancer cells in my leads to
cytoskeleton our arrangement to promote
the metastasis so in summary here are a
few major findings in drosophila ack is
not an essential gene but it's required
for sperm formation ack although it
lacks the quick domain is the functional
home log of mouse act1 the same domain
registry and accounts for me i require
for a state function basically
co-localize with kathleen but has no
apparent world in endocytosis a skip
highness is recruit is required for
recruiting dark and dark it's also
required for snow chances and then asa
hit and dark ASIC NPR to are not
functional redundant ok so that's what
we know about a sick a hub of PR to so
here is the locus of PR tube and then we
actually spend some time to generate
strong mutations in PR two and then they
two examples are shown here emi is upon
occasion in PR 2 and then excision
cellular division poetry so when we
cross
this to mutation together the flight
diet is indicated pr2 is an essential
gene so we move here to function the fly
by the question is why do the flight
died so we spend some time to figure out
where is PR chill required so we put the
black eyed pea are two under different
promoters and what we found is that we
put muscle motor for flies your diet and
about when we put our PR to undo these
neuronal drivers the fly can survive so
what this suggests is that PR 2 is
required for any more survival and this
requirement is required in New on
ourselves and use the rescue looking
again pinpoint which domain is critical
for PR to function so we mutant a kinase
domain we may mutation a permutation to
inoculate the SS freedom and they made a
permutation to navigate the clip domain
and then the kinase domain is absolutely
critical shown here if you meet any
funny snowman you cannot rescue but the
HT toma mutants and then the Cuchulain
are still functional in addition if we
put a ck wild-type it cannot rescue
again shows that the ack NPR two are
functionally non-redundant PR to Trina
rescue ack in span of Genesis and ack
cannot rescue pr2 in you wanna sell
functions okay so right now we actually
have evidence that PR 2 is actually
involved in axonal part finding but
we're going to focus on its connection
to cdc42 because PR chill has the clip
domain and ack does not so to establish
the link we general system to look at CC
42 function so what it's easy for you to
is a small GDPs and it cycles between
the gtp-bound the enough its day and
then the Arctic state and then so we
express a few different cities 42 in
under beta-tubulin syringe um cells so
here include a wild type and then the
dominant negative and then the to
constitute after me so we do it for a
few reasons and then one reason was that
we were actually very intrigued by how
the spirometer along this you go from a
spiritual sell to a 1.8 milliliters are
in addition 64 cells do it in synchrony
how is that regularly and a one thing
we're looking at we're looking at a cup
coating compass college accesses which
target secretory vesicle remember our
hypothesis is that the exorcist actually
localized at a specific location in
Johnson and that's indeed the case here
you can see a sec 3 which is a mem it's
a common of exercise in a spook result
is localized a different places but when
the self divinity long day you can see
accesses are concentrated at a chip
and this Exorcist localization are
influenced by cdc42 so ovarian trick and
shriek but what will happen when you
overexpress series 42 in germ cells okay
so so here's a result so if you
overexpress this for too long time the
flies up photo you can see sperm in
seminal vesicles and then the cell
divisions no more so here you're looking
at the swim with it after meiosis and
then you can tell on the cell division
complete normally quite easy in this
system because after meiosis all the
mitochondria coalesce into a structure
called lubricant as in a dark circle
here and then a live circle is the
nucleus so it is sat if the cell
division will see normally you see a one
dark circle one light circuit
configuration however when you express
activated cdc42 what you see is that
there is no sperm in the seminal vesicle
in addition you see a lot of self with
multiple nuclei associate with
mitochondria that indicates the
cytokinesis were disrupted
so so why does cdc42 well as ectopic
alpha version of 640 to be suave
cytokinesis this was sort of mystery I
think recently a cup of paper from our
fav parents lab and jump from beside
suggests that you need to pivot cdc42
activation are actually activity during
mitotic excellent to allow the septum
formation so if you have too much CC 42
activity during mitosis yah trade
disrupted sup information and you have
the Baron sonic music so what we think
is going on is a mayfly is very similar
and that's shown in this file right here
so here you have cdc42 wild-type label
and GOP is your label go G and then
platinum doing spermatocyte also stay
with the 4g language labor
phosphotyrosine so it's one of cell /
earthly however when you have activated
cdc42 for example the V problem with our
mutant the city's 42 in cell look at the
Golgi a local actual use very strange
structure near the cell surface and this
structure also in which in
phosphotyrosine as you can see in the 4g
10 staying here moreover this a barren
cdc42 structure is not random if you
call stainless cells with a million
which labels the site of cell division
that will cdc42 he thought is localized
for some reason for some reason that
activated cdc42 is recruited to the site
of psychokinesis
okay so what is the meaning so in animal
cells the construction at the mid body
is facilitated by this acting malison
ring the questioning what position the
octo biasing rain fly in the center of
the division plan and a pipe is known
about this process so this past week
while Gookin called central spindling
which associate with the interdigital
central spindles the sensuous mendelian
then recruit a protein called attitude
which is a role gdp exchange factor so
the central spindling recruit active
then you have localized activation of
Rho G TPS which then we are going to rho
kinase were facilitate the formation of
his 80 miles in ring as well as the
subsequent construction of his ring but
this wind does not associate with the
main brain so there's another ring the
septum ring which are formed an
exceptionally is associated with the
membrane and the annealing is an adapter
that linked the actual mass rain to the
south union so as the optimism wing
constricts a million coupled to
accepting we who actually also
facilitated accepting name to constrict
so CC 42 as I shown a previous slide
that are the Occupy version in
drosophila germ cell is Thatcher a
localized to a meaning in addition shown
in here in addition the immune
localization its abnormal in cdc42
activist also here in a wild-type you
see a million nicely nicely nicely label
their cytoplasm bulges in the mutant the
annealing structure are disrupted so
here are dividing ourselves a combo go
image you can see annealing wins I need
cut across is when you see to that and
then 642 wild-type sort of vaguely
associate with that structure but in in
cells expressing activated sees 42 those
onion greens are grossly disorganized so
so what does have to do with ack family
kinases it turns out that PR chew
mutation can suppress this process so if
you look at cdc42 v12 selves about
seventy percent of the germ cell will
have cytokines deeper in the same
background if you mutate one copy or PR
to the deeds that drop on 72 about
twenty-five percent so PR to in genetic
is suppressed that if i suggest that PR
to add downstream our cities 42 input
urban germ cell cytokinesis this
interaction is very specific if you
knock out one copy of a ck you don't see
the suppression so the suppression is
specific to PR to come system with this
we ask as PR to bind to cdc put into the
answers yes you perform again a kawaii
are with our GOP trap they pull down CD
CD for you
to sew in a wild type it does not buying
it does not flow down PRT wild-type by
if you force a PR to wild-type with
activities 42 now you can pull down pr2
so implication there is that PR to
preferentially bind to gtp-bound cdc42
again this interlocking specific if you
do a Calliope with a ck you see no
interaction so the summary here is a
peel out to genetically and then
biochemically interact with our bathing
suits for the two and then how about
localization so here is a mshirley tag
pr2 is localized along a cell periphery
and then here is CC 42 wild-type they
show a little bit of colocalization but
when you have cdc42 v12 again it forms
this a bearing structure near the site
of cytokinesis you can tell pr2 is been
recruited so again 6042 v12 binds to PR
2 and alter its localization so here is
what we think is going on we think
expression of cdc42 v12 which is
gtp-bound form these wap subtle cases
and the way they work is that is some
recruitment event you don't really
understand some some stop some armed
protein that we clue cdc42 in the
vicinity of those emilian rain ceptin
ring or homogeneous cdc42 then through
the interaction with the quick domain of
PR 2 then we crew pr2 to the same site
then pr2 most likely will diamond rise
through the stair automotive and
generate phosphotyrosine and then we cou
some protein which then be stabilized
the win that's critical for cytokinesis
ok and then so at the end so summarized
here we have show you what we've done
with the 22 asala ack family kinases ack
is required for sperm formation and then
act by recruiting doc to form some kind
of multi-protein complex to promote from
production pr2 on the other hand is
required for animal viability and that
requirement it's in New on ourselves and
our current hypothesis is PR 2 is
required for some axon pathfinding in
germ cell when you activate cdc42 you
can disrupt cytokinesis and that effect
is mediated by by PR too but not by ack
i will think that specificity is because
pr2 has a clip domain and ack that's not
so the end I will summarize our
acknowledged ability to work and then
most of what I've described today is
done by a very Tony question about a
dollar who it work on our on ack and
Gisela bars work together our killer
eyes in PR 2 and this work we've done in
collaboration with Jim Clemons Purdue
University and then here the funding
from American Heart Association American
society and march of time and that's the
end of my talk and I will stop for
questions thanks
you